MALE SPEAKER: I'm really,
really happy and excited to let
everybody know that we have
Dennis Wingo here speaking
today.
Dennis is the CEO of
Skycorp Incorporated,
and he spent the last
year, over a year,
on this ISEE-3
Reboot Project, which
I'm sure you guys
are on the website
and seeing the news up until--
I think they had a post about it
this morning.
So with that, I will hand
things over to Dennis.
DENNIS WINGO: Thank you.
And thanks for having me today.
And since I'm here at Google,
I must put on my uniform.
I am a Google Glass explorer.
So, OK, Glass, take picture.
So I really appreciate
being here today,
and everybody that's
watching over the internet,
and including some of our
direct collaborators at Google.
As a matter of fact,
it's interesting.
When you said a year,
I'm going, yeah.
But I'm going, no.
We started this
project literally--
I read a blog post in February
that this spacecraft was
going to come by the Earth.
They weren't going
to be able to save it
because it was impossible to
save because NASA had gotten
rid of all of the
equipment in the 1990s.
And they didn't have a way
to do anything anymore.
And so we're just want to
go by silently in the night.
And I'm going, wait a minute?
You know, I've got
this character flaw
that, when somebody says
something's impossible,
I've got to at least look
at it and see what's up.
And just to give you a little
bit of background about me,
it's not the first
time that we've
adopted an impossible project.
In about 1990, they said it
was impossible for a hard drive
to be able to work
on the Space Shuttle.
And I'm going, why?
Because I used to work for
a hard drive manufacturer.
And we ended up flying
the first MacIntosh that
ever flew on the
Space Shuttle in space
with a big old 5.25,
1-gigabyte hard drives,
and we made that work.
And a couple of years later,
my university said, you know,
it's impossible--
students have never, ever,
ever raised the money
to build a satellite.
We're lucky to raise $20,000
for lights on the soccer field
here.
And we ended up
raising $6.6 million
in cash and in
kind contributions
and built the first
student satellite
that NASA ever supported.
So I've got kind of a history
of doing stuff like that,
and I have a very long
history in engineering.
And I started to work
in computers back when
we called them
microcomputers, even
before that infamous
day in August of 1981
when IBM foisted
the IBM PC on us.
And so this February,
I read that blog,
and I'm going, well, why?
Because I kind of knew
about the spacecraft.
And it was February of
this year, not last year.
I'm going, why?
The ISEE-3, I've always
kind of known about it
because in the 1990s, when I
was at the University of Alabama
Huntsville, I worked at a
research institution called
the Center for Space Plasma
and Aeronomic Research,
called CSPAR.
And at CSPAR, we
studied what's called
the solar terrestrial interface.
It's where the
energy from the Sun
begins its interface
with the Earth,
and this call solar
terrestrial physics.
And so I knew about--
and I've actually
known about for a
very, very long time--
this spacecraft called ISEE-3.
I'm also a ham radio operator.
I got my first ham license
when I was 14 years old.
And if you're a
ham radio operator,
you studied Sun,
because you want
to know when the
conditions are right
for long-distance communication.
This is the internet
of the 1970s.
And so we studied
that, and I used
listen to solar
terrestrial reports.
So I was familiar with ISEE-3,
and I've been familiar with it
for a very long time.
So I'm going, you know,
it'd be a real shame--
so what can we do?
And you start
thinking about this.
And this is kind of
one of the reasons
I like talking to
Google, because it's
about technology advancement.
10 years ago, what
we've just pulled off
couldn't happen-- because
the software wasn't there,
the hardware wasn't there, and
kind of the systems engineering
wasn't there to do something
like this on a rapid basis.
So I started thinking about
in and I did some research
on software-defined radios,
and I did some research
here and there.
And I'm going, you know, I
think it's possible to do this.
And we're very fortunate in
that I have an existing project
that NASA also said
was impossible,
which was taking tapes from the
1960s that hadn't been touched
in 45 years and old
tape drives that
were sitting in a
barn in Los Angeles.
And we put all
that back together,
and we've been digitized
the original 1960s
images of the Moon.
It's a project called McMoons.
And we're at a place
called McMoons.
It's just a stone
throw from here,
over at NASA Ames
in the research
park in the McDonald's,
just literally right
behind the place you
guys just took over.
And so we're kind of neighbors.
And so we've been into McMoons.
We're doing this.
And I'm just going,
you know, it'd
be a real shame
for the spacecraft
not to get used again, because
it's a great spacecraft.
And I'll tell you why.
This is ISEE-3.
The spacecraft has these booms.
And it doesn't have an
imaging system on it.
This is not a satellite
like you're thinking.
But it has very, very
wide band sensors.
And it starts out at RF, like
very low band, short-wave era,
short-wave frequency RF.
There's these booms right here.
These booms right
here-- each one of those
are 41 meters long.
So this spacecraft
has a tip-to-tip width
of 92 meters in space.
We called it-- if it kind
of got off-course and went
through the geo belt--
our space blender.
So we're looking at that,
and it's got magnetometers
for measuring the
Sun's magnetic field,
in it has cosmic ray detectors.
It actually had the very first
gamma ray burst instrument,
and it was the first
instrument to detect
that we had these weird
gamma ray bursts that
were coming from all
over the universe.
And later there was
a spacecraft built
because of this one called
the Gamma Ray Observatory,
and they measured these
bursts all over the universe.
This spacecraft here
literally wrote the book
and invented the
term "heliophysics,"
which is the physics of
the Sun in the modern sense
of the word.
And it's a spinning spacecraft.
It spins at 19.75 RPM.
So that means the
tips of these booms
are whipping around
once every 3.04 seconds.
And it's been doing
that since 1978.
And so it's a really
cool spacecraft.
It's a dumb spacecraft.
There's no computer
on this spacecraft.
There's no software
on the spacecraft.
This is a state machine,
is basically what it is.
It's got a ROM, so they have
a few little stored things.
But it doesn't-- there's no ALU.
There's no processing.
There's no code.
It's all done in what anybody
who's been around that long--
it's 1970s-era CMOS chips.
And so it's a very
dumb spacecraft.
And the way that this used
to work back in the day,
you had dumb spacecraft
and very smart
people on the ground,
a whole bunch of them,
that controlled the
really dumb spacecraft.
Well, we didn't have
the money for that,
and we didn't have all this.
So we're going, what can we do?
So we started talking the NASA,
and fortunately, we know people
like Dr. John Grunsfeld, who's
the Associate Administrator
for Science.
And if you read
the thing-- they're
looking at shutting down the
Lunar Reconnaissance Orbiter.
They're looking at shutting
down Cassini and rovers on Mars.
NASA didn't have any
money put into this,
even if they did
have the equipment.
So we talked to NASA.
And on April the
10th of this year,
we had a teleconference
with NASA.
And they told everybody
who was interested.
And there's a lot
of people interested
in this spacecraft
at NASA, because most
of the senior
management at NASA today
cut their teeth on this
spacecraft or its companions.
There was actually
three spacecraft
launched at the same time--
two were in Earth orbit.
And this was out at about
a million kilometers away.
And so this is what the
spacecraft looked like back
in 1978, before
they launched it.
And then this is a
pretty graphic from one
of its missions.
And here's another
real cool picture.
We just got this yesterday.
And people start
to send us stuff.
And we just got this yesterday.
This is some of the
team members that
put this spacecraft
together before launch.
And so we're starting to
gather these pictures.
So it's not a big spacecraft.
And it was actually
in the era that NASA
didn't have much money.
NASA was spending all of its
money in the mid to late 1970s
building the Space Shuttle,
and so they didn't really
have much money for science.
And so this was a very,
very inexpensive mission.
And that's kind of caused a
few other problems we've had
lately.
So here's the original mission.
What this spacecraft did-- it
was one of three spacecraft.
Two were in Earth's
orbit, circling here
between low Earth orbit and
the Earth's magnetosphere
to measure all of these
parameters, from cosmic rays,
gamma rays, magnetic fields--
everything about the Earth.
And then they had one spacecraft
that was all the way out here,
about 1.5 million
kilometers closer to the Sun
than the Earth, in the
Earth-Sun libration point called
L1, which is a gravitationally
stable area about 1.5
million kilometers away.
But see, the Sun's in the way.
So what they had to
do-- the spacecraft
had to orbit the
libration point in order
to get out of the
interference of the Sun,
because the Sun
puts out more radio
energy at radio
frequencies than anything
else in the solar system.
And so they had to orbit
this point and about 600,000
miles away from it.
And so it sat there.
It measured the
Sun during the peak
of what's called Solar
Cycle 21, in 1980,
and in companionship with
these other spacecraft, studied
all of these parameters.
Well, back then,
these spacecraft
really didn't last
all that long.
It was only a
three-year mission.
And so around 1981, 1982,
they started thinking, hey.
What else can we do
with this spacecraft?
Because there was-- and I
remember this, because I've
always been a science
geek, and I always
remember the NASA stuff.
And at the time, NASA
wanted to send a spacecraft
to Halley's Comet.
They didn't have the money, and
they didn't build a spacecraft.
And a lot of the
NASA guys-- kind
of like me-- were kind of,
you know, this is crap.
We're going to figure
out something to do.
So what they did--
they figured out
a mission for this spacecraft.
Think about what it
took to figure out
the math for this
course back in an era
when you had a mainframe
of maybe one meg of memory
and maybe 100,000
FLOPS of power.
But there's a guy by the name of
Dr. Bob Farquhar-- who I really
think should get the Nobel
Prize for this alone--
who figured out that by doing
several flybys of the Earth
and flybys of Moon, that
you could gain enough
orbital energy to
fly by the Moon--
and they did their final
flyby in September of 1983--
to go and catch a comet.
And they caught this comet
on September the 11th, 1985.
It was the very
first comet encounter
that any spacecraft had ever
had a year before the Halley,
so the "Go USA" kind of stuff.
The USA was the first country
ever to get close to a comet.
And they navigated
this spacecraft
that was not designed
for interplanetary flight
within 8,000 kilometers of the
nucleus of this comet-- way
cool.
And it was just amazing.
And I remember it at the time.
But they didn't have an
imaging system on it.
But they got a lot
of really good data.
And if you go look at the NASA
technical report server, what
you will find is that
there's literally
thousands of papers
written by people
who worked on this satellite,
because literally it
wrote many books
on these subjects.
And then in March of 1986, it
encountered the-- let's see.
Oh, I've got a clock here.
It encountered the comet
Halley, but at about 21 million
kilometers.
But still, even at that
distance-- and this was
a discovery as
well-- Halley's Comet
influenced the solar
magnetic field.
And they still don't quite get
how that works, but it did.
And so after this
encounter, this spacecraft
is in a heliocentric
orbit, about 354 days,
with the Earth at 365 days.
And so these are two ellipses.
And what they started
calculating is,
can we bring this
back to the Earth?
Well, they calculated,
and they set it up,
and they did the
thruster firings.
In 1986-- and the
last thruster firing
was in February of 1987--
for this spacecraft
to fly by the Moon at about 1830
UTC on August the 14th, 2014.
Do you know how far off course
this spacecraft is right now?
20,000 kilometers,
after 27 years.
Come on, guys.
Could we do any
better than that?
[LAUGHTER]
Nuh uh.
These guys got it-- 20,000
kilometers off-course
in 24 billion miles of travel.
Just mind-blowing--
mind-blowing.
So we started thinking
about this, and on the 12th,
we started a
crowd-funding effort.
The 12th of April, when we
started, we had no money,
had no technology, but we had
a bunch of people-- you know,
I'm not dumb, and I've
done a lot of stuff,
and I've been around this
business a long time.
And I'm going, you know,
I think we can do this.
So what we did--
and right here, I
want to show you one more thing.
We have the tyranny
of Isaac Newton.
This is the other thing
that we were fighting.
Because this
spacecraft, we knew,
was a little bit off course.
Well, 20,000 kilometers
is still a very long way
when you want to pass by
the Moon at 50 kilometers.
So we knew it was off course.
And to change the
course, you have
to fire the propulsion system.
In order to fire the
propulsion system,
you've got to talk
to the spacecraft.
In order to talk
to the spacecraft,
you've got to understand
the spacecraft.
You've got to stroke it.
You've got to be nice to
it, just like a kitty.
But we had a problem.
We had a Delta-V curve.
This is how much Delta-V,
in meters a second,
it was going to take to make
the course correction we had
to make in order to fly over
the Moon at 50 kilometers.
And this number starts
really going up.
It's asymptotic.
As you might think,
the closer you
get, the more energy it
takes to correct your course.
Well, that number starts--
and this is seven.
This is July,
where we're at now.
And we're going,
the spacecraft only
had about 140 meters a
second of propulsion left.
Well, here we are 1st
of July-- we're already
at 100 meters a second.
We're going, oh crap.
And so we started right here.
And so we're going, what
the hell are we going to do?
What have I got
myself into this time?
So we started thinking.
And as good engineers,
whether you're
a software engineer, a hardware
engineer, you think, OK.
I've got-- there's
an old saying, if you
have enough problems, you can
make them solve each other.
So I started
thinking about this.
I'm going, OK.
We don't have a transmitter.
We can't use any NASA dishes,
because our deal with NASA-- we
actually signed a Space
Act agreement with NASA,
but NASA can't
give us any money.
So NASA can't give
us any facilities.
And all the big telescopes,
all the big antennas are mostly
NASA or other
government agencies'.
I know people in a
commercial business,
but the biggest dishes
are like 13 and 15 meters.
We needed a big dish.
We needed a really big dish.
So I'm going, hey.
There's a really big
dish in Puerto Rico.
It's called Arecibo--
the biggest frickin'
dish on the Earth.
I wonder if we can use that.
So we went to Arecibo.
And we talked to
the guys down there.
And fortunately for us,
they had had an earthquake
in Puerto Rico a few
months before that
caused some problems
with that big structure
in the middle that holds up
all of the communications gear.
And so they had, literally
only a couple of weeks before,
started operations again.
So they weren't really
back up to full speed
with all their science
and all that other stuff.
And so they had
some time for us.
And it just so worked
out that the time
of day we wanted to do this was
at the end of their maintenance
period.
And so these guys always
put a little padding
in their maintenance period,
and so we could come in there
and use the antenna then.
I went, all right.
I got the biggest antenna
in the frickin' world now,
so I've just solved one problem.
OK.
But it also solved
another problem,
because I needed a transmitter.
Well, NASA usually, with their
big 34 and 70-meter dishes,
they have a 10-kilowatt
transmitter.
Anybody got a clue
what the lead time
and cost of one of
those suckers is?
It wasn't going to happen.
Well, Arecibo to
the rescue again.
I only needed a
400-watt transmitter.
I talked to some
people on the internet.
I found a guy in Germany
who built power amplifiers
for ham radio.
I said, I need one in two weeks.
He said, OK.
And I think I about
drove him crazy,
because I think he signed up for
something impossible as well.
And he was about a week
late, but we still got it.
And at the end
of-- it was May 29.
Now, we started the
project on April 12.
I swear to God we hadn't
written a line of code,
hadn't built a
piece of hardware.
May 29.
Success.
We commanded the spacecraft to
go into engineering telemetry
mode.
One of the cool things about
the spacecraft that the guys had
done who built it before, or who
had operated it before-- they
left the transmitter zone.
So that was a beacon
that we could lock on to.
Well, we found out that
the ephemeris that NASA had
was wrong.
The spacecraft wasn't exactly
where it was supposed to be.
But, another side
benefit of Arecibo--
any of you guys here
communications engineers?
You know anything
about communications?
Well, OK.
Think of a dish.
Think of a telescope.
Think of anything like that.
You have what's
called a beam width.
So if I've got a
small antenna, I've
got a really wide beam width.
If I have a big antenna, I
have a narrow beam width.
And this is how we
communicate with satellites.
But if I've got the biggest
telescope in the world--
and I should have
thought about this--
I've got the narrowest
beam width in the world.
The beam width of this
telescope is 120 arcseconds.
So I've got to point that
sucker really accurately.
And you ask, how the
hell do you point
a dish that's
anchored on the Earth?
Well, they have an azimuth in
elevation on the center part,
and they get about 15 to
20 degrees of elevation.
And they can do a
full 360 in azimuth.
So they can point the dish.
We've got a 120 arcsecond.
But that's accurate
enough that we
could do what's called
passive Doppler.
And so they could
point the telescope,
and they point it the next
day, and point it the next day.
And so just like the guys who
find asteroids and comets--
and they don't have
transmitters on them.
And this is how they
determine their orbits.
And so we were able to get
a better fix on the orbit.
And guess what?
This asymptote number turned out
to not be anywhere near as bad.
This was based on
250,000 miles off course.
NASA didn't have
confidence in themselves.
But when we were only 20,000
kilometers off course-- and I
won't jump ahead.
We're going to try to do
a [? burn ?] tomorrow.
We're down here.
Whew.
So this right here--
we put the spacecraft
into 512 bits per second and
we were able to get the data
and start to assess the
health of the spacecraft.
Ah-- not that data.
But I wanted to show you right
here-- this is how we did it.
This is a company that's
right here locally called
Ettus Research.
They're right over
here in Sunnyvale.
They're owned by
National Instruments.
You guys didn't buy them.
Somebody else did.
[CLEARS THROAT]
And they build a
software-defined radio
called the N210 USRP.
It has about 400
megahertz of bandwidth
and can go up to
about 6 gigahertz.
So this right here
was our radio.
Instead of trying to build
hardware-- modulators,
demodulators, all that
stuff-- we were able to use,
via Linux in an application
called GNU Radio,
we were able to build in
software in three weeks
something that
normally takes a year
to do, in terms of
building hardware,
building systems to be
able to control and operate
a spacecraft.
We did this, literally,
in three weeks.
And this is kind of a slightly
more advanced version of what
we were doing, but this
is how we operate it now.
We call this HA by
Static Mode, and I'll
let you figure
out what HA means.
It was our-- let's
call it "half-baked."
And there's another
word in there.
We transmit from Arecibo.
Because we know where
the spacecraft is now.
And we have a group working with
us in the amateur radio world.
We have a dish in
Germany, a 20-meter dish,
and a radio telescope called
Bochum Observatory in Germany,
to where we receive.
And so we're able to receive
telemetry at the same time
that we're
transmitting, so we're
in what radio guys know
as full duplex mode.
So we can determine what
happens to the spacecraft.
And it's really, really improved
the way that we do things.
And so we use Skype--
we actually have Skype.
We have guys calling out values.
Because we have this
little problem called ITAR.
It's a four-letter word.
I can't tell these guys what
all the telemetry values mean,
because it's in a
document that we
got from NASA that's called
an ITAR document, which
means that if I export the data,
tell them what the data is,
I can go to jail.
So my brain is a controlled
item by the US government.
It's been that way for years.
And so what we do-- they
read off the numbers,
and I'm on Skype.
And we have another guy over
here translating the numbers.
And so I tell our
other guy, who's
on the other laptop commanding
the spacecraft, what to do.
So literally we have
recreated, in eight weeks,
an entire ground station
network that's global in extent.
We have other ground
stations-- one's
at Morehead State in Kentucky.
We work with the
[? city ?] guys.
We've got some other dishes
that we were just offered.
So this is kind of how we
operate the spacecraft.
This right here tells
you a little bit
about what we actually did.
This is called a waterfall plot.
And what a waterfall
plot is-- it's
looking at the carrier
from the spacecraft
along with its Doppler.
Because a spacecraft
moving through space
will have a Doppler
effect on its carrier,
and we can measure that.
And then you do a waterfall
plot so you can follow it.
Well, what this
is here-- we were
able to test out the
spacecraft, and this
is what's called ranging mode.
And this is coherent
ranging mode,
where we actually send a
waveform to the spacecraft--
and these are the sidebands--
and the spacecraft jumping
frequency.
So we determined
that we would be
able to range to the
spacecraft and use the Doppler
effect to get an even better
position on the spacecraft.
Because we have to
reduce our uncertainty
in the position of the
spacecraft to less than 5
kilometers in either
direction-- actually closer to 1
kilometer uncertainty
in its position in order
to fly by the Moon
at 50 kilometers
and not hit the Moon.
So, again, uncertainty here.
And so we built the
command structure.
We're reading the telemetry.
We're doing all of this.
We're moving along.
And then this right here
is just some of the data.
And I think this is probably
the coolest data to me,
because I do a lot of
spacecraft power systems work.
These temperatures
are right in line
where the spacecraft
was 30 years ago.
The solar arrays on this
satellite-- everybody
loves solar power.
Google loves solar
power, and all this.
But solar arrays degrade.
What we found out about
these solar arrays--
that they were still
at 93% of the power
they were putting out in 1980,
when Jimmy Carter was still
in office.
So that was a major
revelation for NASA.
And that right there
justified the money
that NASA put in the project.
So what we're able to
do-- and this is the value
that this brought
to NASA-- is they
wanted to understand what the
health of this spacecraft was.
Because by doing that, they
can confirm their codes.
Everybody likes to have
their code validated.
So the thermal analysis from
back then they can validate,
so they can go back.
And believe it or not,
the thermal analysis code
that NASA uses today
originated in the 1960s.
It's just been
translated from Fortran
into more modern applications,
but it's still the same base
code.
And so they came very close
to good thermal analysis
within a couple of
degrees of everything,
within a few percentage points--
just absolutely fabulous.
They did great.
And so we verified all of that.
And then so we kept operating.
And we still operate
the spacecraft.
This is our operations
facility today, the McMoons,
with our pirate flag.
And that's an inside NASA joke.
But this is our operations, back
in what used to be the kitchen.
We have our guys and gals
in there doing their work.
We do a pass.
We have a decent
internet connection.
I'm telling you.
When you guys take over
the airfield there,
please get us some
good internet in there.
Because it really sucks.
I was using DSL until
a few weeks ago,
where we finally got a
decent internet connection.
But we use the internet and
the GNU radio here at NASA Ames
to connect to the radios that
are at Arecibo, through SSH.
And so we can send our
commands to the radio,
through a private network,
a relatively secure system,
to be able to command
the spacecraft.
So that's what we do, and so
we do our passes here now.
Well, everything
was going great.
We were doing good.
We tested the propulsion system.
We spun the spacecraft
up from 19.16 RPM,
and it slowed down a little
bit over 27 years, to 19.75.
It worked great.
And last week, we
were all going.
We hit the button for the
final propulsion maneuver
to put it on course
to fly by the Moon
at 50 kilometers on August
10, and this is what happened.
This is kind of like pressing
the gas on your electric car
when your battery's
about 95% dead.
It has a similar effect.
[ENGINE DYING SOUND EFFECT]
Well, it turned out
we had a problem.
And we have been
debugging that problem.
And I just put out an article
on this on my WordPress site
and on our
spacecollege.org site.
I've come to a realization.
And this is partly because of
the people here in this room
and on this campus
and everywhere else.
We now are the board.
We have a global
collective consciousness.
And how that worked
in this instance
is that-- I'm not a
hydrazine propulsion--
I've got to see
which one I have.
OK.
I'm not a hydrazine
propulsion guy.
My expertise is, mostly,
I'm a systems engineer.
I'm a systems architect.
My detailed experience is in
communications, computers,
and power systems on spacecraft
and in the computer industry.
I worked 20 years in
the computer industry
before I ever started
playing with space.
And so I wanted some help.
So what we did-- we
put out a blog post
on Space College and NASA
Watch in two or three places.
We need help.
Within two hours, I had
90% of the biggest experts
in the world, both
from US industry,
aerospace industry,
from NASA, from DoD,
as well as international,
to help us with our problem.
Instantly-- almost instantly.
So we were able to
take our telemetry
and talk to these guys.
And they kind of talked
us through the issues.
And we sort of
figured out that, OK.
I mean, when this
first happened,
we were all depressed.
We're going, oh.
We're out of fuel.
But now we've
figured out that we
may have a problem with what's
called the latch valves.
And these are valves inside
of the spacecraft that
block the propellant tanks
from the rest of the system.
And there's details of why.
But these guys that are top
people in the world-- we
talked through all
of the possibilities
and came to the conclusion
there are these little valves.
So not only did we diagnose
the problem of the satellite
from that far away, we use
the collective consciousness.
And I say probably 98% of the
professionals in the world
are on the internet--
probably 99%.
That 99% in professional
roles, that is a brain trust.
That is a collective
consciousness
that can help solve
problems, can help do things.
And I think this is a
very profound observation,
and a very profound thing that
we've been able to do here.
But the bottom line is that
we're going to go tomorrow,
and we're going to go
through at Arecibo,
and we're going to try to
propulsion system again.
We've got some things to try.
And I think we have a pretty
good chance of doing it right.
So what are we doing?
What are we doing here?
And I want to show
one slide here,
and I'm just going to
show it for a minute,
because my friends--
we're actually
working with Google
Creative Labs right now.
Google Creative Labs has been
with us since the beginning.
And I know sometimes people
describe Google as an ant
colony, and sometimes
the ants don't
know what the other
ants are doing.
But you have a
great organization
called Google Creative Labs,
and we're working with them
to build some interesting things
that will be revealed soon.
And you know how
things are around here.
We can't say everything,
but real soon.
And some of our collaborators,
Suzanne Chambers and the guys,
are working with us.
So we're going to have a Google
Creative Labs crew at McMoons
tomorrow, working with us.
So we're having some
fun there, and we're
going to show some really cool
stuff very soon-- next month.
And so I'm just going
to show this again,
but then I'm going to
show where I'm going.
Because we're getting
up to that time.
And I want to open it
up for some questions.
This is what I want to do.
Why am I doing this?
We want to do it,
one-- everybody
said it was impossible, and
we want to do stuff like this.
The other is that I want
to showcase my company.
You guys know this.
I don't know how many of you
guys have your stock options,
but everybody knows that Google
and other companies around here
are vying for space right now.
I know about Google WorldView.
I know about O3b.
I know about many
of your projects.
And I know about many of the
other projects around here.
Well, one of things I
want to do is say, hey.
We know what we're doing.
Our little company
knows what we're doing.
We do the impossible.
My gig is doing stuff like
this-- building spacecraft
on orbit.
And that's just
my little teaser.
Because we know how to do
it better than anybody else.
People might say
this is impossible.
I'm telling you--
this is how we're
going to have ubiquitous
global internet, not CubeSats.
That's my part there.
And with that, I'm going to open
this for questions how ISEE-3
and what we're doing.
Because we've got about
10, 15 minutes left,
and so we've got plenty
of time for questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm pretty sure we have
seen this [INAUDIBLE],
so is there any risk of someone
hijacking your spacecraft?
DENNIS WINGO: Well,
they would have
to know a lot more about
the spacecraft than what
you can find out.
There actually is a
lot of information
about this spacecraft
on the internet.
But one thing that's not out
there is the command codes.
And those are actually
ITAR-controlled as well.
So they're not out there.
When we do our pipeline,
there's a white list of IP.
And, yeah, somebody
could probably break in.
But, you know, why?
It would take a lot of effort
to replicate what we did.
And at the end of
the day, you couldn't
have that much fun with it.
AUDIENCE: Would you say
satellite control systems
have changed significantly?
Like, 20 years in the future,
can current space-- would
it ever be possible to do this
again, or is stuff more complex
now?
DENNIS WINGO: The answer
is yes, and here's why.
One of the problems that we face
is incomplete documentation.
It's difficult.
Modern spacecraft-- and
I want to use an example
like Lunar
Reconnaissance Orbiter.
You would really
have to have-- so I'm
going to kind of agree with you.
But one of the problems
is these spacecraft
have safe modes that you can
kind of start with and kind
of build with, and get into it.
And now we keep
documentation better.
So we have a better-- more
ability to go in there
and do that.
But I think there is
some merit in that.
I certainly don't think we could
have done it in three weeks.
But at the same time, there's
a lot of commercial satellites
out there in the geo world.
And one of the business areas
that we're going to move into
is controlling geosynchronous
communication satellites.
I think we can do that a lot
cheaper than other folks.
And so the answer's
only a qualified yes.
AUDIENCE: If the
spacecraft continues
on the same trajectory,
what other things
can you do with it other than
controlling the propulsion?
Can you get more science and--
DENNIS WINGO: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Is it going to pass
interesting areas or something?
DENNIS WINGO: Yeah.
We already have gotten our first
science from the spacecraft,
from the magnetometers.
What this spacecraft
has-- if you're
studying magnetic fields,
you want more than a few data
points.
Well, right now, we
have a whole bunch
of spacecraft in Earth orbit.
We have a couple around Mars.
Well, this one here gives
us another baseline.
And we've already gotten some
good magnetometers readings.
When we put the spacecraft--
even if we don't get it back
in Earth orbit, we're going
to leave the telemetry on,
the science experiments on.
And we'll be able to
get that data, gamma ray
bursts, and things like this.
And so if you're looking
at something that's
six billion light
years away, you
want to have a bigger baseline
than a couple thousand
kilometers or a couple
of million kilometers
to be able to
determine the distance.
So the answer is,
no matter what,
we're going to get good
science out of this.
But what we hope to do is to
put it back into a stable Earth
orbit to where we can
provide, as citizen
scientists, this
data to everyone.
And that's kind of what
we're working with.
And I can't really say
too much more about that.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
status of the solar panels.
Do you have status on other
things in the aircraft?
For example, the
memory-- have there
been bits flipped by cosmic
rays and things like that?
DENNIS WINGO: There
ain't no memory.
AUDIENCE: Ah, no memory.
DENNIS WINGO: [LAUGH]
I'm telling you.
And I don't know
how far back you go.
But it's like a super,
super, super old printer.
Those super old printers
didn't have memory.
You stuffed data
into a register.
And you read data
out of a register.
Those registers are
hard-wired chips
that had flip-flops in it
that are not classical memory
elements.
They're not like a static RAM.
They're not like a dynamic RAM.
They literally are
hard-wired registers
that you can read
to and write to.
That's all this spacecraft has.
I missed [INAUDIBLE].
It has one microprocessor on it.
It's an 1802 that's on
one of the experiments.
But all the memory for
that died 30 years ago.
And this spacecraft has
taken more than five
times its normal radiation dose.
And so, yeah.
There's a couple of bits
flipped here and there,
but you just reset the
register and you're fine.
It is literally the dumbest
spacecraft on the block,
but we love it.
AUDIENCE: I enjoy your
comment about the lack
of documentation, because
I'm a technical writer
and a former military historian.
And what was really good
is to organize the document
for lessons learned.
Is there a plan for
a book or a movie
starring George Clooney
and Sandra Bullock
to document your efforts?
DENNIS WINGO: No.
But what we are doing--
we're actually working,
and we've been working with
them for a while, the Library
of Congress and the
National Archives.
And since you're a
military historian--
I actually worked
on the very first
terabyte-class engineering
document management
system for the Defense
Department in the 1980s.
We had a four-terabyte
engineering document server
in 1985.
In the Defense Department,
because their equipment
has a much longer life
cycle-- like the B-52
is older than
anybody in this room.
And these old weapon
systems-- they
have to maintain those drawings.
So back in the
old days, they had
what's called an aperture
card, which is an IBM punch
card with a piece
of microfilm in it.
My company, along
with AT&T, digitized
millions of those aperture
cards and put them
into a digital database.
This is literally the first
large-scale engineering
document database in the world.
And NASA doesn't
do that, though.
NASA does a really good job
at archiving their science.
They suck at archiving
engineering data.
Every single program, including
the Space Shuttle, the Space
Station, the Saturn
V-- the only reason
that we have the design
plans for the Saturn V is
that a friend of mine
in Huntsville, Alabama
took it upon himself to collect
an entire collection of all
the Saturn V stuff and
stuff it in the library
at the University of
Alabama Huntsville.
Or we wouldn't have the
drawings for the Saturn V.
There is no requirement.
This is government contracting.
There's no requirement in
any of these guys' contract
to archive their product,
their spacecraft.
And so what we're doing is--
and we're working directly
with the Associate
Administrator for Science
and the associate
administrator for what's
called HEOMD, the
exploration guys,
to write in to
Federal Acquisition
Regulations and NASA
contracts that they also
have to have an archival
plan for all the engineering
documentation for the spacecraft
products that they build.
Because I know more about
this spacecraft than anybody
at NASA.
I know more about Lunar
Orbiter than anybody at NASA.
And that's a tragedy in a way.
I saw a presentation
one time when
I started building my
students' satellite.
This is in the early 1990s.
And I get brought to this
company in Huntsville.
Does anybody know the name
of the first commercial space
company?
Of course you don't.
The company's name was
Space Craft Incorporated,
a company called SCI.
That company still exists.
It's called Sanmina, SCI--
the world's largest contract
electronics manufacturer.
You guys probably use them,
in some form or another,
for some of your
Google products.
But at the time in the
1950s when they were found,
they basically invented--
all this stuff about CubeSats
that everybody's waxing poetic
about and all they can do,
they invented that
in 1958 and 1959.
Guess why?
The rockets the US had
couldn't put anything other
than a CubeSat, basically.
I mean, the Explorer
1, the first satellite
we ever launched,
weighed 30 kilograms.
We just didn't have it.
And so this guy's showing
me this presentation.
When I was building
this satellite,
it was 34 kilograms,
that we flew in 1998.
And this guy's showing
me all this stuff.
And I'm telling
him, I said, do you
realize how many patents
I could invalidate?
And this is part of
it in that there's
this intellectual
property that's
developed that falls off the
map, is reinvented later.
And we're like on our
third or fourth generation
of reinventing this stuff.
So to answer your question,
we are working very hard
with the National Archives,
and the Library of Congress,
and NASA to get NASA to do what
the Defense Department does
in kind of a good way.
And I laugh about
this all the time,
because I'm very much of a
technical historian myself.
I have a really good library
of technical documentation.
It predates 1990.
Still, the vast majority
of really cool stuff
that happened before 1990
doesn't exist on the web.
It just doesn't.
And so a lot of these
technologies, a lot of stuff
we do, it's just not there.
And so it's a
continuing process.
And it's going to
be interesting.
And this is the chilling
part-- one of these days,
and it's already happening
around the world,
that governments are going
to be able to control
how the information
is presented.
And when 95% of all
information is digital,
history can be rewritten
at the stroke of a key.
This is something that your
company logo of Do No Evil
can help us fight.
Because there are
companies and there
are nations around the world
rewriting history as we speak.
AUDIENCE: This was
just a question.
Do you have any
gauge on the accuracy
of the scientific instruments
now, and, I guess,
do you have any way
to calibrate them?
DENNIS WINGO: The magnetometer
is working as expected.
We have another instrument
called the bane instrument that
seems to be working as expected.
We have the ability to
calibrate the others.
But we've been really focused
on the engineering side
to save the damn
thing, and then we
worry about the
scientific instruments.
But in the last
couple of weeks, we've
been running in
science data mode,
and so we've been able
to start that process.
AUDIENCE: All right.
DENNIS WINGO: I
want your question.
AUDIENCE: I had the
very same question.
DENNIS WINGO: Oh, OK.
So the answer's yes, and doing
the calibrations and all.
And I think we're going to
have some way cool products,
and a lot of the
coolness of it will
be because of our collaborations
with my friend Suzanne out
there.
MALE SPEAKER: All right.
Well, we're just about out
of time and out of questions.
So if you could
join me in thanking
Dennis for coming
and speaking to us.
It was a great talk.
[APPLAUSE]